hey guys it's evan and caitlin podcast
we're back from our second break ever
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's go with this let's go with it
so we're back we we over scheduled
ourselves a little bit and we were just
like turning away at videos and we're
like just sorry podcasts are you
streaming we're just gonna kind of focus
a hundred percent on our videos and
they're starting to come out now and
they're doing really well so I'm excited
yeah well there's like so for the main
channel videos we have actual sponsor
commitments the broadcast and gaming
channel we don't so unfortunately those
little ones that have to get cut
sometimes when there's crazy but it was
like and we take our commitments very
seriously if we say that we're gonna
have a video ready for review by a date
we're gonna have that video ready for
review by that date and if at that date
the companies like actually could we get
a little extra time reviewing rolling no
we stayed up late we skipped a podcast
for this that's ever happened anyways
anyways so we're back what have you been
doing has anything new happened we
finally had the Popeye's Chicken Santos
good do okay so we referred to this
probably like a few weeks ago yeah you
know in a podcast because we had kept we
kept hearing about it and hearing about
it and hearing about it on Twitter and
different podcasts and this and that and
so we went to Popeyes and they were out
and they said they'll be back November
first we tried it and they said November
2nd and then we had it two days in a row
marketing strategy was so good to like
true martyr by Popeyes I wish he Popeyes
they don't need it at this point
so freaking good they're like I got a it
lives up to the hype I know not everyone
thinks it lives up to the hype like we
went well I went in with like zero
expectations because I had been they've
been you hearing about it yeah well I
was just like punched in the face with a
flavor packet bad that's the story
that's like it comes Brahman oh my god
save
we're doing this podcast my intro was
completely off oh yeah we're gonna talk
about what's new we're gonna talk about
how we shoot videos how we make our
YouTube video answering some questions
from you guys and then we're gonna be
playing youtuber headline or not yellow
game games thank you
and we might we might fit in some extra
cues and it's depending on how fast we
run through these topics so let's start
with um how do we shoot videos we got
this question from Marcus man oh yes and
he's working on making his own videos
he's having issues but with shooting the
work yeah he said it seems more
difficult to get the shots right than it
does to actually do the work do you guys
not only plan out the project time
materials tools etc but also planning
out the various shots and overall
project story how do you guys approach
it yes everything is planned but also
most things are yeah it's tough we have
strategies and like a few are fully
planned but very few if any are anymore
it has been like an evolution should we
walk them through the full evolution we
could okay so in the beginning when we
first started shooting videos and I feel
like this might be easier if you're
someone who's kind of new to it we
planned out literally every shot it also
helped that we were doing projects that
were kind of known yeah you know like
we'd make a simple cutting board or some
concrete letters in a mold and it was
like we could picture exactly the
project yeah it's like you can't predict
a lot of our recent projects because
it's just chaos we purposely like
throwing chaotic like stuff that we've
never done before now and so we we can't
predict it yeah but so we used to plan
out what every single shot would be
literally I would have like would have
it all in a Google document and would
refer to it right okay we got this we
got this let's get this angle let's do
this and you know I think that's easier
when you're first starting out because
it's like foolproof a little more
foolproof yeah and yeah you don't like
worry that you're forgetting something
and like that stress is a lot because a
lot of times you can't go back you can't
like fake things you want to do things
over again which most people don't yeah
especially in
like a project video you can't like
unpainted wood you know what I mean so
yeah so that's that's not a bad strategy
for when you're first starting out and
it also depends on what type of video
you're making I think that back then we
were making more instructional videos
and now we're like come along with us on
this journey as we figure this thing out
yes like we've gotten a lot like a lot
looser about planning out the filming
and stuff and we still do plan the
project like we try to estimate about
how much time it'll take we try to get
an idea of our materials beforehand
because a lot of times we have to
special order stuff and we usually don't
have that much of a lead and so we have
to try to figure that out as soon as
possible so we're not like struggling
last-minute but in terms of planning the
shot so we kind of have like a few
different modes that we'll go into and
we know what type of scenes require what
type of mode yeah so first off there's
like the talking head mode that's a very
frequent thing that we do where it's
like a tripod and it's filming the two
of us and we're talking yeah and filming
in 4k for that if you got if you can
have a camera that films in 4k is very
useful because Caitlin used that to zoom
in in our faces to do pans to like add
some movement to the camera so it
doesn't look like a static still but it
allows us to both be talking naturally
without having one of us distracted by
holding the camera and I guess you could
technically have two different cameras
going on you and we tried that once
having two different angles when we did
the small scale manufacturing oh yeah
yeah and it cut back and forth but
honestly I just like looking at one
camera I know which camera yeah it was
like kind of confusing I don't know if
it was worth it having a 4k camera
I do think really helps for those types
of segments because it gives you the
ability to have some more dynamic shots
and specifically if you guys are
interested in it we'll have a link down
below that lists all of the cameras that
we use we use the gh 5 for that just
because it films like the 4k on the gh 5
is really crisp and it has an unlimited
filming time that's very important and
there's a battery X
battery pack that we plug into it so we
can record indefinitely there's two SD
cards so it'll roll over one to the
other and it's plugged into battery so
you can leave it on all the time and we
have a remote yes very important having
a remote that you can click to start and
stop the recording mmm it's so good
yeah that is definitely super helpful
because otherwise you're always running
around from behind in our case running
around from like behind the workbench to
run over to the tripod to turn the
recording on and off yeah and that's
that's our primary camera running for 90
percent of our shots yeah so so that's
kind of like one type of scene and we
use that for intros outros or any part
where we're gonna be like talking and
explaining so sometimes we'll have a
scene where we often will have a scene
where we go through like the plan like
what our game plan is and it'll just be
recording us you know we'll do the
cut-ins and stuff because the 4k and
will overlay b-roll that relates to what
we're talking about and that's what we
use when we're doing resin pours and
that's a different mode though Oh
different mode so good so I'm still
talking about talking head mode okay
talking about one 4k camera yeah oh yeah
you're talking head boat yeah just the
one 4k camera yeah and then you can
overlay b-roll that you pick up either
earlier or later to like help mix it up
the other filming mode is real we call
it our real-time filming but also it's
like that's like the process when they
like something that's going on yeah yeah
yeah it's like our our I'd call it like
our real time filming mode and that's
when like we are gonna be doing
something where we know we're gonna
capture all of the audio all of the
banter there's a chance something will
go wrong we don't want to miss it so we
use this for resin pours we use it for
like big glue ups sometimes where
there's like a lot of moving parts and
for these scenes that same camera is
always running but in addition to that
we're two other cameras yeah we often
have one to two others so one sometimes
will be a top down and it just depends
on the project so if we're doing like a
resin pour it's gonna be
down but if we're doing a glue up it
might not be necessary and for the
top-down camera it really isn't that
important what camera it is we use our
oil doesn't have to be great yeah I'm 50
I think that ten fifty is a great
starter camera for making videos and we
still like that in general
so we often will put that up there or
our camcorder that we're using right now
to record this podcast just have those
two cameras running pretty much for the
whole scene but then in addition to that
we almost always have a handheld camera
and that's that Canon m50 no Canon EOS
that Canon EOS are like our fancy one
that's one with the blurry background it
has really good stabilization it has
really fast dual pixel focus it's a
great camera for getting pretty shots
but also you don't have to fuss with it
you don't have to fuss with it you can
like grab it as grab-and-go
but pretty shots yeah yeah and so um and
for those scenes we the reason we have
all those different cameras which I know
it sounds like a lot is cuz um you know
we always want to have that front on
camera because for our faces and for the
like show them what's going on yeah like
if you're doing instructional videos it
might not be super important to get your
face in there but for us a lot of it is
based on like our reactions or our
banter and this and that and so getting
our faces is important the top down is
really good for just like an overall
view of what's happening cuz you don't
often get that in the front on
especially again with something flat
like a resin pour or some kind of art
and then the handheld is just to like
introduce movement or get detail
yeah and so they each kind of serve
their own purpose but having the two
tripod ones gives you the flexibility
like if stuff is going down you just
have to go which like often happens with
resins resin or even like glue up
sometimes and things are like drying or
like when we're I'm staining something
and you're finishing something and I
flick my stain all over that we're
actually weren't filming during that
moment but there's often things like
happen where you kind of go into panic
mode you can you can't just like grab
your camera I think there's also one
aspect to this which is unique to to
people who are equal partners in the
youtube channel like when when one of us
is doing something where all of the
focus
on that person doing that something is
really great for like me to pick up like
if Caitlyn is doing something intricate
or interesting I pick up the camera and
I film it so I'm doing something and I'm
not standing there like a big dumb bus
or vice versa you know so I think that
gives us like a way to interact with
each other and have a reason for being
there on camera yeah and like you know I
pointed to your face or I use the camera
to be a character in that moment and I
think that's unique thing of the two of
us it's it doesn't really help you
someone who's like just do doing it by
themselves
but um I think that that moving the
camera around and gesturing and pointing
and stuff it's a great way to like show
something and still be interacting with
the audience even if it was just like
even if you were just a single person
creating your own content for your own
channel like sticking your hand in front
of the camera so that you like the
first-person view
yeah like pointing or like picking up
something and moving it and then showing
some dynamic action I think works pretty
well yeah yeah so that's kind of
reserved for like the most important
scenes where we have all those cameras
going the other mode we go into we call
it montage mode mode is great it saves
our Channel
yeah it's also the mode that I feel like
a lot of typical like instructional make
her videos are filmed in yeah where it's
it's b-roll
it's like b-roll after b-roll after
b-roll and I'm just doing the thing yeah
so it's often more just on like our
hands it's quicker clips will often like
time lapse or it'll just be like quick
shots and it's great for just like
pairing with music especially if you
need to kind of speed up the video so
like part of the question earlier was
like how much do we plan the shots we're
gonna get we know like what type of
shots we need to get for each scene and
as we're filming the video sometimes we
know what the scene needs to be like
again a resin pours
always gonna be the full camera on hand
yeah but sometimes sometimes you know
cutting the pieces of wood might be we
might film the whole thing and it might
be like a couple cameras going and
filmed in real time sometimes it might
be in montage mode where we just speed
right through it most the times this
montage mode where we just speed right
through it know how to cut wood it kind
of depends on like how involved the
project is so if it's a really simple
project we might spend a little bit more
time on the details and not just montage
through them whereas if it's a bigger
project we will speed through some of
the stuff that is a little bit more
obvious like we're cutting wood one tip
that Caitlin yeah one trick the Caitlin
uses a lot when we're making videos is
we kind of edit as we go especially the
intro like the intro is such an
important part of our videos which is
the feel it establishes the feel it like
people decide whether they're gonna stay
or leave during that moment yeah so I
think especially during the intro like
knowing that you have an intro like good
before you even like get into the
project is a huge weight off of our
backs and it's not something like hangs
over our heads the whole time we're
filming like is this even gonna be good
but it's interesting a lot of people
that we've talked to they don't film the
intro until after the whole things down
yeah and we have done that before um
just trust yourself that your future
self is gonna come up with yeah but I
think it's like for us we're not very
good actors and so we like we like a
little bit of genuine uncertainty first
look for certain things I've often
wondered like is it gonna get annoying
that we're always uncertain but that is
true we we do kind of put ourselves in
situations where there will be
uncertainties because I think it makes
for more interesting videos and it's
kind of exciting and fun and you know it
would be weird to film an intro and
we're like man this sure is gonna be
hard I hope we can do it and like we've
already done it you know but if we
haven't done it yet then we could be
like is this gonna work or like you know
it's hard to like make for
fiction's of what's can have in the
future and flashback to them if you've
already done it you know yeah and
sometimes we like to make predictions
it depends I'm like what had the video
you're making if you are like some
people might present the project all
from the past like I know Chris from
four-eyes might sometimes do that or
well I think a lot of people so they
film the whole project and then they
write their voice over I know some
people write the whole voice over and
then film the project to that voiceover
I did a thing does it where he writes
everything and then films to that that
makes more sense for his videos that
yeah cuz it's almost more like a video
essay with making involved yeah I think
so interesting yeah so everyone has has
different things and that might that
might be a good thing to test out like
if especially if you want to do mostly
voiceover then you can kind of plan it
out more kind of like we were saying
what we used to do in the beginning that
can take away some of the unknowns and I
will say like one thing to just accept
is that filming a project is gonna make
that project take at least twice as long
yeah and that's just how it is
it doesn't really cuz you're making that
much - like interrelated yet separate
things you're making the prada physical
project and then you're making a video
and an AA time the video takes longer
most times they do creating the video
itself yeah more hours goes into making
the video than it does making the
project now that depends on what a style
you're filming in like Jimmy dressed or
Laura conf you know yeah it's a lot
faster for them yeah it was more just
kind of montaging through everything
yeah no no Laura I'm not sure how long
it takes her to set up her lighting and
her shots in there I said that editing
is pretty faster yeah yeah I'm doing
consent a long time on editing days felt
the urge to bust into song
I think the the like relief of like
getting out of that busy period is still
like hitting me and I am glad to be
coming out of that beard anyways don't
harp on that yeah but yeah I think
hopefully that's helpful and hopefully
that gives a little bit of insight and
into how we do it our system has evolved
a lot over the past two and a half years
yeah I think that we actually haven't
even talked about all the different ways
we film I mean like we still do skits
every now and then and that is oh yes
it's a totally different totally
different we write out every shot like
in detail like oh it's gonna be a zoomed
in part of your face and you're gonna be
looking to the side and you're gonna say
this word you know and we like plan out
costumes and oh my gosh we just recently
oh yeah
skit won't be out yet but we did one
where we it was all in front of the
green screen and costumes but we didn't
want to buy double the costumes so we
just bought one costume and we both wore
it and filmed ourselves separately and
combined er combined us in post together
to form one full video yeah I think one
thing that like takes a little extra
time that we don't do all the time but
when we do like it's I don't know it's
very fun as when we do like little
filming tricks like oh yeah we're like
you're moving at normal speed not a
speed or I want to do stop-motion again
that's so much fun
it's so finite we know we don't like
have time for it when we're in rush mode
yeah when we're not in rush mode it's
really fun to like add in those little
touches and like it's not 100% necessary
but it makes us happy and we like when
people notice like well how is Evan
moving at light speed and you're not at
lights being what is this magic and
we're like hey hey hey it's it to take
magic and those things take a little bit
of extra planning like specifically for
that one like you know if Evans moving
at half speed and I'm moving at normal
speed we have to plan like when you're
gonna switch from like crazy speed to
to normal speed and I have to be it a
part of the video that yes not blocking
one of us leaves or enters the screen
that's easy to I kind of cut it in there
but if we're gonna interact we have to
like plan everything out in our minds
beforehand so yeah I can get complicated
yeah so that's like you probably don't
need to worry about that immediately
stop motions are a little bit easier
yeah but I think in general it is good
to have something about your videos if
you are gonna make videos it's good in
general to stand out so you can like
when someone is telling their friends
about your channel that your videos that
you make well it's gonna be the thing
that sticks in their head like you're
gonna love this channel it is blank or
they do blank or whatever it is
sometimes that that thing comes in with
the filming sometimes it's not
necessarily with the filming yeah a lot
of times it's with the story or the plot
or the yeah unique approach towards like
the people themselves yeah but sometimes
it can be brought in with your filming
like just to talk about some of the
examples that we already brought up like
Laura comp super beautiful maker shots
like everything's so well shot like her
workshop school always does why Frank
how are those really cool stop motions
like super elaborate really cool
stop-motion or like the the two of them
on screen at the same time or something
you know he uses a lot of those tricks
and you're always like looking like
what's gonna do this time Jackman's
always like doing shenanigans where he
likes you know slams his fist down on a
glue up and all of a sudden all the
clamps are gone you know so like you can
definitely add in a lot of personality
with the shooting and editing um so I
think it's one of those things where if
you enjoy that kind of stuff cuz it does
take even more work to do fancy things
yeah if you enjoy that kind of stuff I
think it's cool to do I wouldn't try to
do it if you don't like it because it
just adds a lot of time yeah but I think
that in general the the benefit of our
approach where we just like film a lot
is that we don't worry about missing
something but then the downside is
there's a lot at it for Kaitlin so it's
like in general for our videos we have
way more hours and minutes of foot
than most people who make videos like us
you know the interesting thing is there
was also an in between we've gone
through phases where we filmed
everything all the time all the time
instead of just for certain like we
never had a planned montage mode we
would film everything as if everything
was going to be in it and then I'd
figure out which parts were real time
and which parts were montage any more
editing flexibility but also they also
overwhelmed you and just didn't allow
you to do as much super overwhelming
yeah that's like when edits would take
me like five days they're behind us and
I think there might have been at some
point in which we were like right after
we got back from Alec Steele we were
like let's feel nothing yeah and so we
were like we don't need to have any like
real time stuff will you there just be
top we'll have a quick shot where we
talk to the camera or it'll be montage
mode quick shot where we talk to the
camera or montage man Alec is so
impressive he at it's wall he films so
basically like editing in his brain
mm-hmm so he'll film like the montage
mode and then he'll film a little
talking break then he'll film another
montage mode and then he'll film like an
explaining bit you know and basically
all his editor has to do is drop all of
the clips in shorten them time them into
music do all that stuff but like yeah
it's already done yeah and he like if he
does a bad take he'll just delete it and
do it again yes there's no like worry on
the editor like to like know which one
it is it's like everything that Alec
gave his editor was pretty much good
yeah and it just had to be like massaged
and treated a little bit yes and we can
do that with like montage mode type
stuff but when it comes to anything
we're filming in real time it all needs
to be reviewed and every bit of it needs
to be set decided like is this funny do
we keep it do we cut it because we
emphasize you know it did did it Evan
like make a funny note noise three times
in a row so I'm gonna emphasize it every
time yeah or you know you just have to
like watch it and see what is there I
can't snap my fingers and Kaitlyn camp
snap you there
we can't be funny like that yeah we
can't just yeah yeah we can't we can't
turn on the funny we can have humorous
moments where we say if anything or we
do a funny thing cuz that's just us you
can't like if someone like points the
cameras and like says be funny we'd be
like yeah that's why we can't just like
like only record when we want to say a
thing for some parts yeah yeah sometimes
like I'll have a funny thought in my
head we're not recording I'll record and
say it and sometimes it's good and
sometimes Caitlin's like I wasn't good
[Laughter]
to see if it was gonna be a good thing
like we've literally had multiple
multiple notebooks like that like I'm
gonna try something funny that wasn't
good what you see in the video is us is
is us being real but at the same time we
cut out all the bad stuff yeah it is
yeah it so much does get cut and it's
funny cuz our videos are now like the
average thing is pretty long over 20
minutes yeah yeah there's this we just
film a lot so yeah I'm not sure if
there's any like answer to what's the
best way to film video but how do we
shoot video that's kind of our strategy
and you know there is no one best
strategy for YouTube I think we've said
it before we've said it in like our how
to would we title that like how to how
to start a YouTube channel yeah we said
that in that video the podcast there's
no like single answer but maybe you can
take some inspiration from us I think
the biggest tip that we can give is get
a 4k get a remote so you can start and
stop it remotely yeah I mean that's
probably the best yeah and if if you
have the ability to get the second
camera even if the second camera is your
phone I think for certain scenes it's
really good especially if like there's
two things you want to capture and you
can't capture both on
like your face and the thing you're
working on for like a far back and a
close yeah you know I think it's
interesting to mix it up and it like it
speeds up the pace of the video - yeah
and when you have like two things going
like that it does take a little bit
longer to edit sometimes because you're
making decisions like which video which
which camera am I going to show this
thing from but it speeds up the process
of making the thing because like you're
not constantly having to switch the
camera around as much because at any
given moment you have two cameras going
yeah well hopefully that was interesting
hopefully you maybe someone picked out
some tips on that or maybe you just like
now look at our videos in a different
light and say oh oh that's a real-time
face oh that's a montage yeah you can
kind of like follow along with our
videos more but that's fun I'm not sure
if we we had a few more questions I'm
not sure if we have time to do those and
the games no maybe we save those other
questions and we go into the game yeah
it's game time again
I think I was like one beat off because
I started okay so sorry so many people
are like listening and not before
watching but we always dance during game
music but usually I like to end with my
fist over on this side like I was
threatening to punch okay so don't look
so we are going to play a game we've
played this once before but I'll explain
it just in case you didn't miss or in
case you didn't catch that episode
it's called youtuber headline or not
where I read youtuber headlines some of
them are real some of them I have made
up and Evan has to guess if they are
real or not mm-hmm are you ready no I
need to get a drink okay I'm ready okay
don't look oh and you can get bonus
points um for when it is a real one you
can get bonus points if you know the
character yes youtuber accused by fans
of a scam after her Louis Vuitton
giveaway turned into a mess okay that's
very believable because there are tons
of giveaways and often times they can be
a mess Louis Vuitton can you can you eat
it one more time youtuber accused by
fans of a scam after her Louis Vuitton
giveaway turned to turned into a mess I
think that is true and it's Lele pons no
it is a female youtuber and you do know
her name like it's from like the like
lifestyle type section I discuss a
random youtuber who I'd heard of one
even watch her videos mo Chamberlain no
no no she's no she wouldn't be that
that's like different different style
I've heard of her you've heard of her
but we've not watched any of her videos
we know
oh yeah and it's real by the way okay
III thought I thought it might be real
yeah I give up
yeah yeah I mean you wouldn't get its
ELISA violet oh I wouldn't have gotten
that at all
yeah she was like Jake Paul's
ex-girlfriend Oh which we know from the
shame doc Dawson
Wow yeah and so apparently there was
just like she did like a Instagram
giveaway yeah and then everyone was
commenting and then it was crazy because
it was like one of those giveaways where
you have to like go follow this brand
and it was a brand called cheeks or
something
sounds like butt cheeks oh yeah maybe it
was for butt cheeks I don't know I think
maybe was an underwear company called
cheeks that'd be great I don't actually
know what the company was but it was the
company it's funny that it was a company
giving away Louie Vuitton give away so
it was like a photo of her with a bunch
of purses like no Vuitton purses but
it's coming and called cheeks and then
like the people who won like we're just
go stood for weeks and then like
eventually she replied to two of them so
one of them was like oh you were too
young to actually be a legit winner and
the other was like oh wait will you
weren't in the US she didn't actually
win so I think there's only actually one
winner but then like before the giveaway
stuff had been sent out that company
cheeks went under oh you're like no
longer had an account and so it just
seemed like this crazy giveaway scam
because like nothing I don't know if
anything actually and I don't I don't
know if things actually got sent out but
everyone was accusing of her was
accusing her of the whole thing being a
scam yeah yeah it took a week for
winners to be announced and then yeah
none of the three winners receive their
prizes oh man and until recently they
couldn't even reach Elissa violet or
cheeks Oh cheek sorry underwear for only
one cheek that's what the brand is yeah
so that's crazy
why no there's there's been a lot of
like you like giveaway drama like people
will like post Amazon gift
cards and then none of them work and
then they like one person called Amazon
and the gift card had been redeemed
before the person even uploaded the
video so he was giving away like expired
Amazon one more ok family youtubers sued
by school for hiding incognito cameras
on children
what man there's something like like
some family vloggers super wholesome
good intention it's good stuff some like
it just like this is a completely
believable headline unfortunately and
I'm gonna say it's true just because
it's so believable that one's fake I
made that one alright cuz like I feel
like like I could see something the only
thing that I think like might not happen
is I don't know if a school would sue or
not I may be a magic spell zone or
something yeah they might get like
expelled but I I feel like youtubers are
always like pushing the boundaries and
trying to do like incognito stop yeah
and I could totally see something like
that happening I don't know wow I try to
think think of things that were like oh
yeah I'm you you you can't came up with
a very plausible thing thank you
australian youtuber saves his dog from
getting eaten by a shark what I think
that's so unusual that it's true because
I think that isn't something that you
just like randomly make up that one is
true yeah did he video it yeah he was
videoing it's like a shark diver and
this the story was recent but it's I
think it didn't happen recently but the
story was recent um but he he was diving
with like a group and I don't really
understand how shark diving works but
apparently they dive with guns I guess
like if something goes down they can
shoot the sharks well what a shark
anyway now it's dark
meme I mean the boys me and the boys
yeah so he was like with a group and a
bunch of had guns are they they all have
guns yeah is like protection I guess um
and he started to notice like all the
sharks all of a sudden started behaving
differently and they all started like
swarming in this one direction and he
was like oh maybe they like drop some
bait off the boat or something his dog
had jumped from the boat
oh no there wasn't but there might have
been that the puppy might have just like
jumped oh my God he's like rushed over
swam over insta was like punching sharks
left and right like bumping him with a
gun like everybody else is like
defending him everyone like they all
like rushed to them happy and they were
like like punching sharks with the guns
and he rescued the puppy and got the
puppy back in the boat oh my god the dog
has never jumped off again oh my gosh
the GoPros strapped to his chest or
something some sort of I don't know
exactly the camera but I'm assuming
something oh my gosh oh my gosh that's
so crazy yeah yeah so the youtubers name
is Brody Moss he said that was his
scariest moment in the water I don't
wanna watch it because it's like seems
too scary yeah we we had a dog for oh no
I'm not lookin okay so we had a dog when
I was growing up and when it was a puppy
oh just follow us around all the time
like do whatever we did so one time we
were going out under the jacuzzi and it
was you know jacuzzis are hot or a hot
tub is the generic term whatever and we
hopped in and our little puppy just jump
in right after us and we didn't think
that he would I don't know I don't know
I waited like assume that he went but
like he jumped in and he is he hated
water ever since then he's never jumped
in any pools and he like never would
like never would like splash in the pool
he'd try to bite the water cuz he
thought the water was evil and bad
like us from the water yeah so trust
issues with water yeah I imagine that
this Australian dog
youtuber trolls LeBron James after study
finds that youtuber is more light and in
some of these I'm putting the word
youtuber like somebody like that's why
the word youtubers I advise it like says
the name well I recently read on Twitter
that something like that was true oh oh
feed by this caption oh I get bonus
points
you guys Beauty bag good job I mean like
it's not hard but it's not hard to be
like more liked in the public opinion
than LeBron James right now because of
the whole that's true that's true and
it's like of course PewDiePie would
troll him I wonder if LeBron blocked him
after that I don't know I mean maybe it
is interesting though thinking about
traditional media versus new media yeah
and it's like it's it's interesting cuz
someone could be like within a certain
age group or you know more popular than
someone from traditional media but there
still would be a total amount of people
that like didn't know who that youtuber
was yeah another interesting thing is
youtubers in general are more in control
of their own public image than
traditional that's true like traditional
celebrities celebrities yeah I'm kind of
like well like what's a better term for
celebrity because it's like yeah that's
like celebrities I think I don't know
why but TV and movies where I was like I
think a sports person I guess is still a
celebrity but it's just like a weird
like what makes it a celebrity in the
Knotts library LeBron James is a
celebrity I guess but his teammate Joe
basketball celebrity cuz like yeah
that's true I don't know yeah anyways
and you know LeBron does have his own
Twitter and he could like make a message
or he could do a tweet or something but
like that's not where most of his
audience consumes media yeah you know
and I feel like there's probably
restrictions on what you can tweet
because you're not just representing
yourself you're representing the teens
and all that stuff yeah the NBA and what
I was like you know we have no signed
anything it's like we do we Wow yeah
YouTube's not like hey you guys can't
say that they can't control us you know
our parents popular gaming youtuber
hands out 100 Nintendo switches for
Halloween Wow 100 Nintendo switches so
that's like two or three thousand
dollars no how much I don't know how
much of it just looks like 200 I mean
less now than when they first came out a
hundred he handed out 100 100 100
that's the law
yeah I saw you need that number for that
title you know yeah oh my gosh can't
hand out 47 I mean it's complete it's
completely believable but also I doubt
it because then everyone's gonna know
where he lives and a lot of youtubers in
general don't want people to know where
they live it's not necessarily handing
it out from your home there's a lot of
like immunity things you like go out to
a place and hand it out while he's like
go out trick-or-treating at the mall you
know did you ever do that no I did once
so it's like it's not like people are
coming to his house trick-or-treating
and he gives them a switch then they go
buy another costume come back
again and again and do it again just
like ask to borrow someone's caution
when the psych cycle get all the
switches this is a tough one it's like I
I guess I'm gonna say - have I said true
- every single one okay true you're
pretty closer I haven't thought about
the angle of like oh yeah everyone would
know where he lived
and you came up with that uh but no but
there really is like community
trick-or-treating like I've done
trick-or-treating at the mall before
there's like various things because
especially like you know if you live in
an apartment complex and you might feel
we're just going to a random
neighborhood but are you and your
apartment complex friends go to this I
should have gone with my gut reaction
and said false just because of the you
you you you you pulled me along pretty
well with that hope community things so
good save good save on the trip I don't
actually know how much that would cost
I don't know how much a switch goes for
I just chose a hundred because like you
you pulled it off really well I'm
curious though I just felt like 100
would be a good number for like a
thumbnail and title $200 okay yeah so
two hundred thousand yeah twenty
thousand that's like people
oh yeah people have done it before yeah
like twenty thousand dollar giveaway and
abuse has done it yeah so yeah Wow it
was within the realm of like fiscally
irresponsible but also like within the
realm of yeah irresponsible if the video
did really well and never sponsored and
maybe you only maybe the sponsoring
company is a Nintendo and they gave them
to you okay next one youtubers canceled
costume has sparked a lot of debate on
the internet for being insensitive Oh
canceled costume can you describe the
costume to me I feel like if I
scribe or not described I can't I can't
give you like too many details so the
canceled Halloween costume was it
portraying a specific person in in the
costume it was just like a cancelled
text canceled themed costume canceled
like being canceled false that's true
what was the costume it was just like
I'll show you so the youtuber is
Jacqueline Hill the one with the hairy
lipsticks oh yeah yeah and so it's just
like a black dress with the word
cancelled on it and she's like bloody oh
that's strange but people were saying it
was insensitive because she was I get I
think trying to like make a statement
about how cancel culture is scary like
you know what did she say not one day
has gone by in over two years where I've
not seen your cancelled online so I
wanted to create a look showing the glam
side showing the glam side of this
industry and the ugly so here it is you
want me cancelled you got it I know my
haters are gonna hate the costume that's
okay I love you anyway
yeah so the reason people said it was
insensitive is because like the reason
she was quote-unquote cancelled is
because of the quality of her lipsticks
where they came out and they were like
hairy and lumpy and I think like I heard
hearing lumpy but I feel like I heard
like kind of moldy or something yeah and
so the push back against her tweet in
her costume was people were like no this
wasn't just like people decided not to
like you one day you put out a health
hazard yeah I like people so people were
like you know you put it actually bad
dangerous unhealthy product and you're
trying to like spin it into a thing like
oh look at me I'm a victim it wasn't
like without reason that people are
upset with her you know
yeah people were upset because they were
like like they felt like her making that
statement was her
she shouldn't have been cancer um and so
they were like no actually you put out
something that was a health hazard yeah
so that was the pushback ah that's
interesting yeah all right
I know these bootie gurus and their
drama so much drama
smell that peas well Dante okay
you tuber in trouble with IRS after
sharing tax hacks series false okay
another thing the reasons I'm not sure
well I guess it could be a really good
YouTube video like in terms of like the
title and thumbnail and and everything
and there are like finance channels
there are stuff like that I don't know I
just like I feel like people would be
attracted to something if it was you
would have like ways to save money on
your taxes I feel like you would have
like given a disclaimer to protect
himself or something or herself I'm
gonna stick with false just in case it's
funny cuz a lot of times and we haven't
done a video like this in a while but we
have a couple videos that are about like
how to sell stuff online and like
small-scale manufacturing like if you
want to make your own products because
we used to do that and often times in
the comments people are like what about
tax stuff you guys aren't gonna go over
tax stuff and we're like no not a thing
it's like well if you live in this state
and if you live in this country and if
you are in this situation and if you're
married this is you make or create your
company as an LLC or no what about an S
corp
[Music]
it's like so caveat II oh yeah there's
like no way to go over you useful or
reasonable yeah and like of course we
are obviously not tax I express no yeah
it's interesting cuz like people wanted
it and I'm where I'm like I will
recommend starting an LLC for most
people who want to be youtubers or make
things and that's about as far as I can
go and even that don't take that
recommendation for everything you should
form a separate entity have a form a
separate entity yeah what works best for
your situation
yep yep that does concludes the one and
only tax help with avenue felix latest
youtube craze hot dog challenge leads to
widespread Costco sponsorship wait what
I'm trying to wrap my head around those
words you just saw so this is
technically not a youtuber yeah I think
so
okay okay let me judge it from a few
different angles one that's so specific
again don't like you're a very creative
person thanks for grabbing my chin
someone's like looking up in the corner
okay so youtuber trend hot dog challenge
sparks widespread Costco sponsorships I
want this to be true and it's plausible
and it seems so out there that I don't
think you made it up so I think I'm
gonna go with true final answer what do
you think the hot dog challenge is how
many hot dogs can you hotdog if a hot
dog tastes good
so it's false
I thought it was really good I just
wanted that to be real I was like wow
Costco sponsorships I mean that'd be
good for Costco I think you know oh but
can also be dangerous could what is the
channel and oh I should have thought of
this what if the challenge goes too big
and people take it too far and then cost
goes being held like responsible
something they would do that yeah I was
trying to think of like what the hotdog
challenge would be and I came up with it
just cuz I was like what's a dumb
challenge name yeah dog challenge but
then I was like I need to come up with
what it is in case it gets ever asked
hey what is it okay so first off you put
as many hot dogs in your mouth as you
can you have to try to eat them one at a
time I like the how many hot dogs keep
it in your mouth this is sponsorship why
did he say widespread Costco
sponsorships one at a time Keith would
win Keith would totally keep some try
guys got big mouths but yeah you gotta
just eat one at a time the rest you just
hold in place that's horrible I hate it
youtuber arrested for naked IKEA stunt
hmm gosh I like IKEA
I don't know about anyone would be naked
and I hear a stunt what do you think the
stunt would be it's just seeing if you
can shop at IKEA make it looks like
stamp I make it I can't talent yeah or
seeing if you can hide in IKEA naked
like you get naked and you hide for as
long as you can without security kicking
you out and arresting people I think
one of these challenges needs to be
right because one inspires other and
since the other one was false this is
true this is true what is the challenge
it you were pretty close it's it's part
of I think it's called the fort
challenge where you try to go into a
store yeah hide and it's like stay
overnight oh my gosh so bad this is why
youtubers get a bad name so the youtuber
is called his name is max Lee oh jesus
let's not promote him his name is booby
buddy pants I mean we don't know
anything about him but yeah so and he's
like the son of a famous Taiwanese TV
actor it says yes so the challenge is
the fort challenge and he got in trouble
because he was like pretending to shower
and stuff and so he was naked and those
shots like pretending to shower yeah and
I guess and security got him he hid from
security though for a bit oh my god I
was able to hide from them
actually no I don't know actually you
know security didn't get him until the
video in life Wow yeah Oh Graham was
triggered so the guards were alerted but
he was sneaky and managed to avert them
and 9:00 a.m. he can be seen leaving the
store telling a member of IKEA staff
that he bumped into that he was an early
customer yeah yeah so it wasn't until
later so he spent the whole he said the
whole night there successfully Wow
but then it went viral and IKEA reported
it to the police crazy oh my gosh she
took the channel down from social
channels oh my gosh oh yeah yeah just
the video yeah so yeah apparently it's
the fort challenge please don't do the
pork chop
yes I'll do the floor challenge only do
the first part of the hotdog challenge
because that might be kind of funny
thank you but what about a standard-size
of hot dogs during hot dogs have
different diameters so you need to like
standardize on a brand and size you know
don't put too many
rolls on it you squish the fun it's not
about standardized rules well that's
that's a wrap for our podcast I don't
know what the music is so my thing of
the week is Oh ring tool all right so
guys I got this because of my last job I
was building industrial equipment and
you have to install a Rings and remove a
ring from stuff and basically it's just
like an ice pick but there's all sorts
of little twists at the end there's
gonna like dentist tools that's scary
like more stout more like Hardy so it's
like Jimmy always carries around his ice
pick and uses it for things jimmy joste
and I like like a straight pointy thing
but the best tool in the odom tool is
this like an ice pick and it has a
little C at the end there's a little bit
and it's so great for doing so many
things that I have like three of them
around our workshop and around our house
and I just use it sometimes you just
need a pokey thing with a little bit of
curve on you sometimes a little curve of
that NABBA thing
yeah but then grab a thing do like polka
thing unclogging yes okay scrape a thing
yeah it's just like such a handy thing
so all post you know the link down below
will be a 4-pack that I that I've gotten
before that um you know it has all of
the the ones that you need straight the
right angle the the I think one is a
little bit of a curved circle and then
the the see which is the best yeah
the see one yeah so that's my thing a
week just because I use it all the time
so my thing of the week speaking of
jimmy joste
is a video it's on the bone Appetit
channel but it's with Brad Lyon and
Jimmy dressed up just like two of our
favorite people they're two peas in a
pod they're two peas in a pod they they
mesh so well together
and it's so great like we like Jimmy's
videos in general his normal ones but
like it's so fun seeing him like his
personality come out with Brad like
having someone to bounce like jokes off
the pot like they're making a podcast
yeah but in his videos you know he
doesn't really talk
he's like a master of making but I like
Jimmy you know I want I like hanging out
with him hanging out Brad if I hang out
we me like watching the videos yeah yeah
but that's what the videos are kind of
you know it's like it was a little bit
about yeah third person hangout yeah and
so I'm in this video so there's a
two-part series the first part is the
only one that's out right now I believe
but they make a grill together um so
they're like welding and this and that
and it's hilarious there's somebody shot
so just like close-up on Brad's face is
going to gazaís watch till the end
though because some of my favorite stuff
yeah they're like little blooper bonus
scenes yeah I love it I love so much but
yeah it's it's it's really funny I'm
excited for part two and we will have a
link to it yeah so yeah so it's good
good wholesome video good wholesome
content to people you really like yeah
okay well I can't like sense that I'm
like more rusty on the podcast I'm like
Oh words do I say at the end my words do
I say at the beginning thank you guys
for listening
rate is five stars five stars on
whatever things you can rate on mainly
Apple Apple it's like I'm fine with
Apple but apples not they're like hang a
podcast yeah I don't why can't you read
it on pod whatever or like pocket caster
or Google why can't you just think the
rating in your head and broadcast to the
future in the future that's what it's
gonna be
yeah then it'll be so easy to rate in
review yeah but then what if you rated
like what you honestly think instead of
like what you mean to think oh yeah what
if it's like a friend of yours has a
podcast you don't really like it but you
want to give them a five-star support
but then you give it like a
star and your names assigned to and
they're like I see you don't like my
pockets and then like you like what if
like in the future instead of like
rating at ratings you rate a feeling and
it's like and it's like like the the
ratings are represented by the color
graphs it's like an emoji Oh emoji yeah
now on color graphs okay I feel like
it's like an orange an orange is part
way too angry really that red is angry
blues like peaceful but like if yellows
happy is orange part way between happy
and angry I feel like your system's
gonna break down here at some point yeah
you know what it's a beta it's a beta in
progress I guess thank you all for
joining us in two days
[Music]